saint martin des fontaines en vendée
c'est dans ce petit village de 150
habitants que vit fred 47 ans sa maison
se résume à ce petit mobile homes de 27
mètres carrés voilà ça chez moi c'est
louable demeure si fred essaye de garder
le sourire
sa situation est précaire après un
divorce et la perte de son emploi en
région parisienne ce père est venu
s'installer ici pour se rapprocher de
ses quatre enfants
ce mobile homes devait être une
parenthèse mais trois ans plus tard rien
n'a changé moi c'est pas que c'était que
j'étais à côté de quoi j'ai à ça les
mobil homes leurs dates ans et j'avais
fait des plans de construction de
maisons doux et puis bon ça pas abouti à
cause des finances et la situation s'est
aggravée
sans travail fixe frais doit se
contenter du strict minimum et les
conditions de vie sont rudimentaires
toutes les canalisations d'eau passe en
dessous donc l'hiver quand il gèle et
ben c'est gelé donc ça plus rien quand
c'est comme ça on revient à l'ancienne
donc on va chercher de nos oppose
l'algérie canaux chaudes sulfureuses et
puis on savait pas où la vague ou 11 ans
on s'accommode mon ex femme comprend
très bien donc quand ces gros cons ces
grands froids bas à garder enfants chez
elle autre inquiétude pour se chauffer
l'hiver freine n'a pas une autre choix
que de s'équiper de ce poêle à bois un
mode de chauffage strictement interdit
dans un mobile home et pour cause c'est
que tu vois donc aux or il suffit que ça
tombe au sol
comme lors de ce terrible fait divers en
novembre 2011 où un père et son fils ont
perdu la vie dans l'incendié de leur
mobile home
ce drame a été un électrochoc pour
bernard le voisin de fred salut chef
avec ma femme on sévit ben nous on a dix
fois pire sous les yeux tous les jours
puisque fred ben oui vie dans des mobile
homes anciens voire vieux très vieux mal
isolés qui chauffe avec un poêle à bois
c'est vrai qu'en tant
on savait qu'il avait ces trois gamins
mais on ne fait pas complètement
tranquille quoi ce céréalier à la
retraite décide de passer à l'action
son pari est un peu fou offrir une vraie
maison à fred pour noël avec une
cinquantaine de bénévoles ils remuent
depuis plusieurs mois ciel et terre pour
faire de ce rêve une réalité et les
élans de générosité sont parfois
surprenants qui veut offrir un arbre et
une personne qui vont offrir peintre qui
vont offrir aujourd'hui bernard on
visite un menuisier
comme beaucoup d'artisans de la région
il a été touché par l'histoire de fred
il va donc lui offrir le revêtement des
murs de sa future maison un don de plus
de 4000 euros
parce que nous on est comme ça hein
quand quelqu'un a besoin bah on est là
on essaye d'être ici dans ce monde de
brutes
comme si souvent pour ce qui est de la
maison en elle-même elle sera en bois et
fera 90 mètres carrés soit trois fois la
surface du vieux mobile homes de fred
c'est l'association agricole dont fait
partie bernard qu'il a en partie payée
avec un don de plus de 20000 euros
ses adhérents détiennent la palme de la
générosité il 100% voisinage au fil des
mois et grâce à internet
l'histoire de fred a même dépassé les
frontières vendéenne c'est avec fierté
que bernard va lire aux membres de
l'association les derniers messages de
soutien reçus
j'aurais bien proposé d'aider mais
j'habite l'irlande
peut-on vous envoyer des dons merci et
bonne chance
juliette des témoignages poignants qui
font chaud au coeur de nos bénévoles et
cerise sur le gâteau des producteurs
veulent même adapté l'histoire de fred
au cinéma or l'histoire était magnifique
et ils vont faire une proposition de
contrat
la rumeur dit que ce sera deux par dieu
du fragment rôle si bernard le sourire
aux lèvres
ces derniers mois n'ont pas toujours été
facile pour lui je pense que ce sera
celle là la porte d'entrée celle là ce
sera la porte du seul levier entre
formalités administratives et tenu des
travaux
ce retraité se bat au quotidien pour
pouvoir tenir les délais une vraie
course contre la montre surtout pour la
livrer pour noël l'objectif c'est qu'ils
passent pas ce quatrième hiver dans ce
foutu mobile homes quoi on habite
beaucoup de temps pour avoir le permis
de construire et on rentre dans une
période où vous voyez on a de la pluie
donc ça nous gêne un petit peu et ça
nous tracasse
malgré ces aléas bernard n'a jamais
perdu espoir
et quand on lui demande s'il est fier de
participer à une telle aventure
c'est pas de la fierté ceux du bonheur
pour pour les autres depuis contente de
toute l'équipe
je lui
pour donner un toit à fred et à ses
enfants juste avant les fêtes une équipe
de bénévoles se relayent sans cesse sur
le chantier un mois après le lancement
du projet les fondations sont déjà
installés c'est pierre paul jacques
françois ou les autres qui lorsqu'ils
ont quelques minutes a honte sur leur
temps et bien ils viennent donner un
coup de main demandez comment ça se
passe pour la toile ce n'est pas une
surprise fred c'est exactement ce qu'il
attend d'ailleurs il met la main à la
pâte
tous précisent bien tout le monde se
coordonnent et puis non c'est hâte de
voir la voir monter puis surtout voir la
tête de mes enfants quand ils vont
l'avoir vous remontez quoi la nouvelle
maison de fred est construite sur le
même terrain que son mobile home cette
terre il l'a acheté quand il est arrivé
ici c'est son bien le plus précieux
pendant que l'on finalisent le montage
de l'ossature bernard bien vérifier
l'avancée des travaux
bon si tu vois des petits des fonds
frais de biens pas de défaut énorme
il a fallu douze semaines pour
construire la maison
le pari réussi pour bernard et les
nombreux bénévoles fred un vrai toit
pour noël
et puisque c'est un petit événement dans
toute la région s'est entouré de
nombreux journalistes qu'il reçoit
officiellement les clés de sa nouvelle
maison médicale parce que je ne sais pas
si la dernière touche finale la pose de
la plaque d'entrée et cette fois c'est
la marraine du projet nathalie renoux
qui s'y colle trouve que je suis
vendéenne
du coup on m'a appelé en me demandant
d'être marraine
l'opération j'ai trouvé ça magnifique
que des gens soient solidaires d'un
voisin dans le besoin dans la précarité
et puis j'ai dit oui tout de suite
spontanément c'est avec beaucoup
d'émotion que fred fait le tour du
propriétaire à son plus grand fils
alexandre et à sa belle-fille de quoi
salon salle à manger est au fond la file
là où c'est que je pourrais quand même
recevoir mes enfants le bo de la jma
julie d'istres alors là normalement
c'est ma chambre c'est ali pour des
personnes s'est tenu dans cette nouvelle
maison d'une valeur de 120 mille euros
fred dispose de trois chambres d'un
double séjour et ce n'est pas tout
radiateur équipements sanitaires et
décoration les bénévoles ont pensé aux
moindres détails pour que ce père puisse
enfin accueillir correctement ses
enfants moi j'aime bien ça vous le
couleurs claires comme ça ça donne des
idées comme s'installer ici par exemple
les cas maintenant non non avec cette
maison fred va pouvoir démarrer une
nouvelle vie
une seconde chance qu'il doit à tous
ceux qui l'ont aidé et surtout à bernard
entre les deux hommes plus rien ne sera
jamais comme avant
bernard sait pas qu'un voisin c'est
deuxième paire copains
un hadji surtout à la vie qu'on a pu
faire
c'est vrai qu'une maison pour noël
difficile de faire mieux comme cadeau
quant à fred il a retrouvé du travail et
son histoire sera prochainement adapté
au cinéma dans un film qui pourrait
s'appeler mobile homes
[Musique]